what's going on reject nation Greg Alba
here and I'm John we are gonna watch the
cinematic trailer for the video game and
thumb I just show John the gameplay
trailer did a reaction to the gameplay
trailer or a long time ago whenever that
came out with III I'm happening as of
today of this video being uploaded
wanted to give a heads up that even
though I have been getting back into
gaming for realz this year beat a few
video games this year I feel like I'm
not as up-to-date as I'd like to be and
I still have gamer friends who are a lot
more knowledgeable and better at
articulating about video games much
better than I am those friends are not
available to come by
until the evenings of Monday through
Wednesday this week so it might not be
on top of the e3 trailers as you'd like
us to be I will be on top of that Last
of Us one though because I did play The
Last of Us so that's just a heads up
hopefully more of you guys will watch
this video secondly Pedro the day
shout-out for Tyler hey Tyler Hague I
just did a Google hangout with this home
buddy he lives all the way in Wisconsin
dude has an epic haircut with an epic
beard sexy mofo we talked with him this
dude had this crazy setup in his house
livestream of something going on a
livestream and then another thing going
on livestream of another thing and then
a Google hangout with us truly living in
the future is like an episode of black
mirror in the making and a beautiful
handsome man while at that Tyler if I'm
ever in Wisconsin were cuddling
and left our world in chaos creating
altering destroy Neil Blomkamp's anthem
anthem BlueCross
they're just alone coming these walls
can't protect us forever
[Music]
1:06 Wow
it's ready go underwater yeah
oh whoa
it's way too real really good graphic
Wow
ha
it's a cool remix too
bad game what's rad dude oh man I I love
how this is not franchise so I can get
up to date with this and it comes out
it's actually funny you brought up Neil
Blomkamp's name because it looks
definitely like something out of his
yeah yeah I mean from the gameplay
footage to this cinematic trailer this
looks like the kind of game I can
absolutely get into oh yeah this
post-apocalyptic like sci-fi world the
ruins the creatures all of it looks just
so wonderfully thought-out and
wonderfully designed with some badass
characters you would love to feel like
you are I'm the kind of guy when I play
a game I'm talking out loud way too
often and then like the talking is upon
the character what I'm playing the game
before I'm talking to the character and
this looks like a great setup for some
franchise material because there's so
much world you can explore here it's an
open-world game the javelin suits and
the different like add-ons you could
have with it this feels like it can be a
game that can just get increasingly
crazier and better every time some of
the stuff they were talking about - with
just the way the game plays out they
were talking about this as a contagious
open-world or something like that is how
they describe it and like the look of
the different creatures and the fact
that they're like these storms and
things yeah the environment looks
beautiful and amazing and yet like the
creatures and the action parts look
really intense this looks like if Neill
Blomkamp made the movie and nya Latian
yeah it looks like one of those things
where like half the time I would be
there just like admiring how beautiful
everything is and then like really
freaked out around something you know
called a cinematic trailer but it's not
exactly a story trailer so you get like
these cut the images of cutscenes and
everything the story is still not fully
realized yeah at least in my eyes I mean
I'm sure the game stories actually fully
realized I'm not sure exactly what it is
yet we've got the vague idea of like
you're one of these freelancers is gonna
go out and explore and I mean the trash
channel is yeah and contain keep the
inventory in hey that's this looks like
my kind of game and I'm very excited for
from the gameplay to the cinematic
footage I'm completely on board would
just I mean the way they've rendered all
this is beautiful I can't wait to drive
six hours up to Dan cyberarts house and
play this game with
alright guys were you excited for anthem
please when the craziest III trailers
drop gonna go by largest requests one
where you decide with the Friends of
what to cover so please leave your
comments down when those trailers are
dropping so we can just filter it out
with the most requested know what
together because obviously we are
primarily a movie talk channel for e3
always make the exception to covering
some video games anyway guys you can
subscribe to the reject nation click
that notification bell and check us out
on patreon a lot of goodies we offer
over there